ce lundi a aussi été marquée par le
quatrième jour du procès en france des
attentats de charlie hebdo de montrouge
et de l'hyper cacher il doit durer
jusqu'au 10 novembre
onze personnes comparaissaient devant
une cour d'assises spéciale au tribunal
de paris
elles sont accusées d'avoir fourni une
aide logistique aux frères kwasi à amedi
coulibaly en janvier 2015 les précisions
sur place de notre reporter katia pique
nique
c'était une quatrième journée très
éprouvante dans le procès des attentats
de janvier 2015
aujourd'hui nous avons examiné le
déroulé des faits qui se sont produits
en particulier le 7 janvier 2015 donc
date de l'attentât de charlie hebdo
christian dos de la section
antiterroriste de la brigade criminelle
est venu détailler quasiment minute par
minute la chronologie des événements et
des images absolument innommable ont été
diffusés la scène de crime dans les
bureaux de charlie hebdo un véritable
carnage avec des corps étendus au sol
énormément de sang des certaines
victimes ont été abattues à bout portant
évidemment face à l'horreur des victimes
et des parties civiles ont quitté la
salle certaine ampleur bien évidemment
des réactions à ces photos et vidéos
épouvantable de cathy richard qui est
défend le fils de bernard maris ce lui
aussi tué dans cet attentat
il va falloir remettre de l'humanité
dans ce procès parce que ce qu'on vient
de voir c'est inhumain
on a vu des machines de guerre on a vu
des machines de guerre crié en arabe on
a entendu des machines de guerre crié
allah ouakbar crier al-qaïda et je pense
qu'il va être très important de répondre
à cette barbarie par l'intelligence par
la culture une question également été
posée à christian dos de la section
antiterroriste amedi coulibaly a été
identifiée dès le 8 janvier alors
pourquoi avoir attendu le 9 janvier une
heure après le début de l'attentât de
l'hyper cacher pour diffuser sa photo au
public
christian d'eau a expliqué que diffuser
une photo précocement dans un terroriste
peu à bout
dire à des vrais drames encore plus
important que l'attentât lui-même
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet la
réaction d' axel metzker qui est avocat
des parties civiles
je veux dire dans ce dossier ce qui est
très présent rencontre c'est qu'elle a
bon dos la religion ils se font passer
pour des religieux ils en ont rien à
faire c'est un prétexte est pourri je
dis ça parce qu'ils seront poursuivis
pour des faits qui laissent à rougir le
moindre religieux quelle que soit sa
religion
donc franchement ces deux noms diffusion
de la photo reste le point faible des
pouvoirs publics parce que on ne
comprend pas pourquoi alors qu'ils ont
l'information que tout le monde mérite
de savoir la presse et même la presse
les policiers moi mes clients ont
demandé mais pourquoi la police à la
photo et pas nous pourquoi on la voit
pas et serait permis peut-être de céder
donc ça a permis de ne pas débattre de
l'écologie ça termine 2 et donc le
lendemain ça c'est pas ça recommençait à
la surprise générale ali riza paul est
le principal accusé qui risquent la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité a fait
une demande en liberté on écoute les
explications de son avocate isabelle
coûtant peyre nom alors je voudrais
rappeler qu'il a quasiment
quotidiennement demander sa mise en
liberté depuis longtemps pourquoi parce
que il a rien à voir avec cette histoire
et que par ailleurs je rappelle quand
même
le principe c'est que la liberté ces
principes et l'emprisonnement en plus
avant d'être jugé c'est l'exception ça
fait cinq ans et demi qu'il est
emprisonné il n'a rien à voir avec cette
histoire et il devrait être libre donc
c'est une demande parfaitement normal
donc j'espère bien que cette espèce
d'inversion du principe de la
présomption d'innocence cédera au fur et
à mesure des débats sur la réalité de ce
qu'il est et je rappelle qu'il n'a rien
à voir avec cette histoire
voici pour cette journée très éprouvante
mais qui permet par petites touches de
faire davantage de lumière sur les
attentats de janvier 2015